I've been a flight attendant for six
years it's a hypersexualized and
glorified job
because of the intense pleasure of
trying to confirm to the beauty
standards of these Airlines a lot of
flight attendants would resort to
plastic surgery I personally know a
flight attendant who passed away on this
is really evil from doing rifosuction
some of them would utilize drugs such as
heroin cocaine math or ice to keep their
weight down you've got Crews who are on
psychotic medicine
and they're still flying during an
emergency you are not mentally fit to
handle those nerves it's dark cool you
are supposed to stand for yourself
you're being prostituted to serve
powerful figures this passenger
requested one of my colleagues to
company him for dinner and the next
thing two of his bodyguards were outside
of her hotel room to take her to see him
just have to agree in order for you to
still have your job you have no power at
all
I started flying in 2012 with a
full-service career based in Asia I
wanted to be a flight attendant because
I thought it would be great to have a
job that allows you to travel like you
are literally being paid to go to all
this exciting destinations
I did not foresee this other sites of
the industry
you are always trying to avoid incidents
on what you do have to be aware of how
intoxicated your passengers are on one
of the flight a passenger started Master
building while watching porn eventually
he started taking his clothes off and
ended up urinating himself and that's
when the crew members decided that they
need to restrain him
did they try to clean him up and put his
clothes back on but he already saw
himself
your seniors will tell you just squeeze
a few eye drops into passenger string
when they become too intoxicated and
they refuse to stop drinking I've seen
this happen a few times and the
passengers always go to sleep after that
it's actually very common to touch
people having sex on board
and it's always an awkward conversation
when you know that they're definitely
having sex and you're there to stop them
from doing it
I've caught a couple on the last row
having sex
they weren't exactly quiet while doing
it
I was stunned at first so I went and
asked them to stop and they weren't
stopping at all
they weren't even embarrassed about
being caught doing that
one of the most memorable experience I
had was having a passenger that tried to
smuggle guns
the enforcement officer had to come on
board and arrested a passenger he was a
gang member from a neighboring country
and he was on the run this man tried to
smuggle two guns both of the guns were
fully loaded the gun could actually gone
off in the cargo because of the pressure
and everybody was pretty pissed at the
realization that this guy is trying to
smuggle something that could jeopardize
the entire flight
that's not really a penalty for violence
against the crew members
once this passenger was upset that she
wasn't sitting next to her boyfriend and
when we try to explain that it isn't
part of our job to make sure that you've
got to be seated together she kind of
like she just went ballistic and she
threw hot instant noodles to one of the
crew members face
she was superficially burned and then
the boyfriend actually came over and
started threatening to blow up the plane
and try to punch another crew member the
only punishment they got was they were
banned from flying the airlines again
stop captains will be power tripping the
captain's right to get me to sleep with
him and he asked if I'll fancy some
private time with him and which I refuse
uh went up to my room and the next thing
I knew he was knocking on my hotel room
door I got scared and I just pretended
if I'm not in the room the next day she
will meet your entire trip how this
because you refuse him
the airlines are always hiring that have
increased to be the face of the airline
itself they have a specific look you
have to look slanderous clean every two
years you'll be issued the same uniform
the same size you are expected to always
be able to fit into that uniform they
have a growing manager you are supposed
to go to The Grooming manager in your
uniform and they will pick and poke your
entire appearances so if you gain weight
or you have any skin issues you can get
grounded from flying because you're not
performing to the standards
after six months of flying I had
terrible skin issues so I was grounded
for a month son to see a dermatologist
with the instruction that I have to make
sure that my skin clears up before
unclit to fly again
a lot of flight attendants would resort
to plastic surgery to maintain the way
they look some doing rifle suction face
lifting breast enlargement or getting
their face reconstructed there is also
this procedure that is called fat
burning we would inject this shattering
solution this solution will pretty much
melt your side away but I've seen a lot
of them hospitalized for the wrong fat
burning procedures
I personally know a flight attendant who
passed away on this is really evil from
doing rifle section
it is traumatizing to know that you know
somebody that you have shown with funds
that we and the shark usually lasted
probably a month or two before everyone
would just go back to their normal
behavior of trying to look as beautiful
as they can because they need to keep
the job
the way I perceive Society is sometimes
abnormal because of the perception that
was imposed on me as a father London
after six years being in the industry I
was clinically diagnosed with depression
and it's something that I still struggle
until now
I've seen a lot of flight attendants
spiraled down there's a lot of suicide
in the industry being subjected to
sexual and physical abuse almost every
day kind of like change you
as a person as well
if you start young and you're being paid
thousands to travel to all these exotic
places it can be something that you look
forward to but at the end of the day I
would say
educate isn't worth all the struggles
that I had to endure